do you think the united states as a
global leader as an empire
may collapse in this century
why and how will it happen and how can
we avoid it
can certainly
harm itself severely
that's what we're doing right now
right now the greatest threat to the
united states is internal
countries
tearing itself apart
uh
i mean
i really don't have to run through it
with you
take a look at something as elementary
as mortality
the united states the only country
outside of
war life expectancy is declining
mortality is increasing
that doesn't happen anywhere
you take a look at health outcomes
generally
they're among the worst
among the developed societies
and health spending
is about twice as high as the developed
societies
you look at the charts
all of this starts around the ninth late
1970s early 80s
to that if you go back to that point
the united states was
pretty much a normal developed country
in terms of mortality
uh
incarceration
health expenses other measures
since then the united states has fallen
off the chart
it's going way off the chart
well
that's the neoliberal assault of the
last 40 years
it's had a major effect on the united
states
it's left a lot of
anger resentment
violence meanwhile the republican party
has
simply drifted off the spectrum
it's not a normal political party in any
usual sense not what it used to be
it's a main policy is
block anything
in order to regain power that's its
policy
stated almost openly by mcconnell
followed
religiously by the entire leader of the
entire
congress it's not us that's not the act
of a political party
it's uh
so of course democracies declined the
violence is increased
the judgments the
decisions of the supreme court very
the court's the most reactionary court
in
memory to go back to the 19th century
decision after decision is
an effort to
create a country of uh
white supremacist christian nationalists
i mean
scarcely hidden if you read the opinions
of alito
thomas
gorsuch and others
so yes we can destroy ourselves within
and in fact the ways we're doing it are
almost astonishing
so it's well known for example everybody
knows that
u.s infrastructure
bridges
subways and so on is in terrible shape
needs a lot of repair
the american association of engineers
gives it a
failing mark every year
all right finally congress did pass a
limited infrastructure
say rebuild bridges and so on
it has to be called a china competition
act
we can't
rebuild their bridges because they're
falling apart
we have to rebuild their bridges to beat
china
it's pathological
and that's
what's happening inside the country
take
thomas's
decision in the recent case in which he
invalidated a new york law
this is last october a couple one couple
weeks ago and validated a new york law
going back to 1913.
that required people to have some
justification if they wanted to carry
concealed weapons in public
he went through that with a very
interesting decision
he said
the united states he said is such
a decaying collapsing
hateful society
that people just have to have guns
i mean how can you expect somebody to go
to the grocery store
without a gun in a country as disgusting
and hideous as this one
it's essentially what he said
those weren't his words but they were
the important
you